recientemente terminó esta rueda de
prensa en la que el movimiento semilla
con el candidato presidencial Bernardo
Arévalo dijeron que hoy a las 4:30 de la
de la tarde hora local van a imponer una
denuncia en contra del fiscal
anticorrupción Rafael curruchiche este
fiscal que ayer anunció la suspensión de
la personería jurídica del movimiento
semilla y lo que alega Bernardo Arévalo
y su movimiento Es que este fiscal está
cometiendo prevaricato está abusando de
su poder para tomar una resolución
arbitraria que los están afectando Y que
además se está pasando por encima de la
ley electoral de manera que ellos van a
imponer esta denuncia ante el Ministerio
Público en la tarde También diciendo
aduciendo que esto es una minoría que ha
decidido amenazar el orden
constitucional abusar de su poder a
través de las instituciones penales y
generando insinuaciones y ambigüedades
sobre lo que está pasando al interior
del partido ellos defienden que
absolutamente todas las firmas de los
ciudadanos que ellos consiguieron para
constituirse como partido son
completamente legales bueno y hay otros
suceso ligado a esta investigación y es
el allanamiento de la Sede del tdc por
parte de la fiscalía Qué se sabe sobre
este sobre el objetivo de este operativo
bueno toda la mañana la fiscalía
anticorrupción ha estado en la sede del
registro de ciudadanos del tribunal
supremo electoral lo que se sabe es que
han sacado dos cajas de expedientes del
movimiento semilla donde estarían allí
recopiladas todas esas afiliaciones y
adhesiones de los ciudadanos que
quisieron hacer parte de este movimiento
en Guatemala para constituirse como un
partido político es necesario tener
entre 25.000 y 30.000 firmas y aquí en
este momento Puerta cerrada lo que están
haciendo estos Fiscales además
acompañados de policía cubierta con el
rostro cubierto con pasamontañas es
verificar si pues lo que quiere
demostrar la fiscalía o lo que pretende
Buscar en su investigación es demostrar
si estas firmas o estas personas que se
afiliaron se les pagó y de dónde salió
ese dinero Y si ese dinero puede llegar
a venir de lavado de activos sin embargo
el anterior fiscal anticorrupción Juan
Francisco Sandoval que en este momento
se encuentra exiliado dijo que la ley
electoral de partidos políticos tiene
Rango constitucional y aquí hay algo muy
importante el artículo 92 de esta ley
dice que no podrá suspenderse un partido
después de la convocatoria a una
elección y hasta que esta se haya
celebrado
aducen que la fiscalía de Guatemala está
incurriendo entonces en prevaricato y
deberán responder por atentar contra la
democracia